look we don't all want the same things
[Applause]
[Music]
so it is that time once again where I'm
gonna do my monthly video on lgbtq+ or
representation in media and gonna try
something a little bit different this
time because I'm not gonna be going this
one alone so what I what I wanted to do
was I wanted to start because generally
I want to talk about lgbtq+
representation I talk about that as a
spectrum which it is however there are a
lot of very specific slivers within that
and some of them I know more about than
others some of them I have a better
sense of the representation they have
than others and something that I wanted
to do was bring in someone who is a
member of the lgbtq+ community but who
is not in the same sort of boat that I
am in the sort of gender fluid
genderqueer transgender ish umbrella and
instead sort of fall somewhere else in
there and talk with them about
representation of the kind of sexuality
or identity that they have or as will
probably often be the case the lack of
it so this is my first go at that and I
reached out to a youtuber who I follow a
booktuber by the name of min kobayashi
and she agreed to be honest she
identifies as asexual and and so from
here you're gonna get to see the
conversation that the two of us had and
if this goes over well I may do other
videos of this nature with other people
you know in as I said other members of
the lgbtq+ community so we'll go over
them here and hope you folks like it
okay so min thank you so much I'm really
thrilled you said yes to this
I'm glad we can finally do it so I did
out here because you came out on your
channel a month or so ago as being
asexual and I it sort of just hit me on
the general notion that you know I talk
about LGBTQ representation in general a
lot of it from my own perspective of
gender fluidity and there are some
elements of lbgtq plus that I feel like
I have my head wrapped around pretty
well but there are a lot of sort of
slices of it that I'm like I kinda know
but it'd be really great to get
everything you can't really one person
can only comprehend so much from their
own experiences yeah
and so just so that anyone watching sort
of is on everyone's on the same playing
field then everyone understands what
we're talking about how how do you
describe asexuality yeah okay so
asexuality is a spectrum
it's something that's not just like one
straight thing but normally through
definition it's described as the lack of
or very little amount of sexual
attraction to any one whether no matter
their gender so it means that you don't
have the experiences of sexual arousal
or anything like that in your life but
that doesn't mean that you don't have
sexual or you don't have romantic
attraction to other people which is like
a huge misconception that people are
there are people that are on a romantic
because we identified by romantic
orientation so you have the whole
spectrum there you can be by romantic
you can be a romantic you can be
panromantic heteroromantic homoromantic
you know the whole umbrellas of them
right but yeah it's the uniqueness of
how that all those orientations kind of
go into one thing and then there's also
two other commonly
used umbrella terms under asexuality
which would be grey sexuality which is
more you have sexual attractions
sometimes but very few times it's not
something that's very common in your
life but it does happen once in a while
so it's like the gray in between black
and white so it's on the spectrum there
and then demisexuality which is when you
only have sexual attraction to people
that you're close with it's something
that you can build a relationship and
then eventually you'll have attraction
but it's not something that's to people
in general and being asexual doesn't
mean that you don't engage in romantic
relationships or sexual relationships
that's really up to any person to figure
out how they want to manifest their
sexuality I guess well that is
interesting that's sort of coming to a
sense of yourself and explaining it to
other people a sexuality that you do
have to decouple romantic interest in
sexual interest which are really they're
generally conflated I think by most
people so it's it's one of those things
that you have to kind of remind yourself
it like I think intellectually a lot of
us get that love and sexual attraction
aren't the same thing but they're so
tangled up in each other for most of us
now I don't I don't remember if you had
mentioned in the in your coming-out
video do you know your romantic leanings
or is that something you're still
figuring out it is a very tricky thing
to kind of understand because I've only
ever been in relationships with guys I
don't think that I am attracted to
females but they're very pretty so it's
always really confusing I look at a girl
I'm like man girls but I've never
experienced any relationships with women
so that's how I normally I'm like I've
only engaged in relationships of mine
it's kind of hard to tell romantic
orientation because it's so conflated
with
actual stuff right fair enough now I'm
gonna ask you a couple of questions that
our ones had given I knew no one else
was ever gonna watch this conversation I
probably wouldn't ask you but I'm going
to ask cuz I have a feeling that they're
probably on them in the minds of at
least some of the people who might be
watching this so how do you feel
comfortable identifying as asexual and
are certain that it is not a case of you
haven't met the right person or or or
that it's a phase or that you're some
form of late bloomer
yeah see that's something that I was
told throughout my like entire life I
remember all through high school like
I'm 21 now so I figured I'm like pretty
sure I'm not a late bloomer I'm pretty
sure like puberty should have already
ended for me but that that's supposed to
be a part of that experience but yeah it
really took until I had so I didn't have
a lot of romantic relationships when I
was younger mostly because I was scared
that if I engaged in a relationship then
they you'd want to go farther than I
wanted and that's just like I don't I
don't like you like this and I was
always confused if people were friends
or not like you know to me it's all
confusion in my head and then after I
had after I was in two fairly long
relationships I was like yeah no I feel
like if I can love someone romantically
and not have that sex drive then it's
not a phase right so I think it's really
hard to figure that out though because
sometimes you're like well I just
haven't met the right person right but I
feel like for me it's pretty well like I
think it would have happened by now
and I I would consider that a fair
assessment at this point but I I would
imagine that's probably a question
you're honestly probably gonna have to
continue to deal with well into your 20s
I don't yeah I'm very sorry to say yeah
but it's a phase crowd they cling to
that there everyone's a little convinced
to that I'm just secret
be and as soon as I enter a relationship
with a woman I'll be perfectly fine and
I'm like I don't think so I hate to ask
but how many of the people saying that
are like oh you just don't know and how
many of them are being like Oh once you
date me know most of it I have a lot of
gay friends and I'm like really I'm
always like I'm the one straight friend
in the group so like TV always told me
that you're supposed to be in love with
me but you're not like none of my gay
friends I was like really man I'm just
make friend over there in the corner but
yeah do you find that you get questions
at all about your presentation and by
that I mean it's often it's not a view
held by people I usually like to be
having conversations with but it does it
is still a perspective out there that a
woman makes herself attractive through
things like dressing while doing her
hair wearing makeup which I'm you
visibly do on your channel and and today
that that people kind of assume you do
that for the sake of attraction does
that throw people off as well the idea
that you're doing that but don't have
that kind of attraction yeah I just
assume that people probably guess that
people that aren't interested in sex
wouldn't want to take care of themselves
which is a weird thing it's like it is
where you stop and think about it for
more than a few seconds yeah so do you
like we have turbo Lex and legacy no
like why would I do that like I would
still want to look nice in life even if
I don't want to have sex anyways I don't
understand that but yeah it is something
that I've got in before it's like so
yeah you wear makeup for guys right like
again I think it's the decoupling of a
lot of societal baggage because it's
just a presumption that and I think I
mean it's not a presumption exclusive to
women I think it comes up in
conversation directed at women a lot
more but there's just a presumption that
you look good to be attractive to people
and it's it's much like the idea of
sexual connection romantic connection
always being linked there's just this
notion that Oh
those things go hand in hand don't they
like well they don't have to so yeah so
sort of having having kind of covered
the the ground bases in terms of being
on the same page with everything I
wanted to talk to you about
representation of asexuals in media now
you're obviously a booktuber so I
suspect most of your points of reference
are probably gonna come from that I
never read or I never watched movies or
TV shows or anything else I just only
read which I cannot remember the last
time I finished a book that wasn't a
graphic novel so you and I love
completely different sort of sources but
I mean I I cried asexual representation
to be kind of an interesting thing
because I think it might very well be
the most frequently head cannoned
sexuality because it can basically be
imposed on or young people can make it
as part of their head Canon any
character who does not have an affirmed
sexuality you can head Canon as asexual
I feel like I see that a lot maybe even
I was gonna say despite a lack of much
firm representation but maybe even
because of that people had candidates so
much yeah because Paul I feel like it's
something that was you know 15 years ago
everyone who was looking for gay
representation would be like well maybe
these couples cuz you know the
queerbaiting and all of that but you
know I mean people when you don't have
it you have to look for it in something
else right so you're like oh well maybe
this person and maybe this person and oh
they you know what I mean they haven't
had sex or you know all these things
maybe they are like me like I can
imagine not as a teenager watching like
TV and being like oh maybe maybe they're
one yeah yeah I mean like I've to my
knowledge and again I it's not a mantra
I actually say on the YouTube channel as
much I say a lot of my podcast
I'm allergic to research so I'm a huge
nerd for research the the degree to
which I actually looked into this was
very surface level but in in trying to
find like concrete examples as opposed
to headcanon and fan theory examples of
asexuality I came up with very very
little I know a lot of people got upset
with Riverdale that because a lot of
people are really pulling for Jughead to
be asexual which i mean if he's anything
in the comics maybe he's hamburger
sexual but he yeah he is actually
confirmed i think in the new I don't I
don't read Archie comics but I
researched the comics that I don't
really uh and it says that he's like I
think it's confirmed but right around
the same time as Kevin was the gay he
came out as asexual so that makes sense
so yeah he is confirmed in the comics
and I was I watched I heard he was
asexual and I heard something from his
actor saying that oh yeah he wanted that
before he got in a relationship it was
like how perfect he's gonna be ace so I
watched the first season that I was like
it's not even like I was like oh maybe
they're going to bring it up as bad you
know that common kind of trope I guess
if someone gets into a relationship and
then actually realizes their sexuality
because of that relationship yeah which
doesn't happen how did I yeah the last
like few seasons so it might have
happened that I pretty sure I would have
heard of it it did yeah I think that
that might have made the rounds if that
had happened by now so like I think the
only the only character that I could
find at least in the kind of media that
had a high sort of tread in was there's
a character on Bojack horseman I believe
it's a main character I haven't watched
it though I don't think it is Bojack I
think it is one of his like very close
friends I think it's one of the human
characters okay um again I don't watch
it either I've heard it's phenomenal but
I've also heard it's deeply depressing
and I have not been in a state where I
am already to imbibe but
plead oppressing show so I haven't
watched it but I do know that whichever
character it is that it that it that it
the term is actually said yes he goes to
I think a support group or I don't know
if it's a support group but like a group
for people that are asexual and meets a
bunch of people with different sexual
are different Orion romantic
orientations at that group and I believe
it's a discussion from what like I read
up on it because whenever I look for
asexual characters it only came out this
year but I that one's the first one that
pops up now yeah and then the only other
one that I had and I don't know how many
people remember this and I sent you the
link to this yes he did which is I think
a little seen and even less remembered
film from 1999 called the opposite of
sex which is a very weird movie my my
memory of it is that it's good but I've
not seen the whole thing in a very long
time but Lisa Kudrow in that one plays a
character and I I kind of wish I could
show a clip but I know I'll get I'll get
copyright hit if I do that so I'll just
have to describe it for folks who
haven't seen it she I mean she she plays
a role throughout the whole story but
she has a scene in a hotel with a friend
of hers and she basically tries to
explain to him her lack of interest in
sex and though the term asexual is never
used that is very clearly what she is
trying to explain to him which is like I
I don't see the appeal what is the
appeal of swapping fluids what if I came
up and blew my nose on you would you
like that I would rather have a back rub
and it's it's and having at least three
watched that scene it seems like a
pretty solid slice of representation
again though in a movie from almost 20
20 years ago that I don't think anyone
remembers yeah yeah from the scene I
watched it seemed like it wouldn't
represent every single person but it did
definitely like some of it I was like
yes yes so knowing that you are far
better red than I am have you had any
luck finding a setae sexual
representation in anything that you read
there is one book that I haven't
actually read yet it just came out this
year and I know it's going the rounds on
book to you but it's called what's about
what's know let's talk about love by
Claire
cam and it's a bi romantic asexual
character that she's the focus and the
focus is around her trying to have a
romantic relationship with someone and
it not be sexual and her previous
girlfriend broke up with her because she
wouldn't have sex with her and all of
that fundus that is the only book that I
know of that has straight-up asexual
representation
well since since we have so few examples
of actual representation that means we
get to leap into that little bit of
weirdness I talked about which would be
asexual headcanon and I have some of the
more popular sort of headcanon asexuals
at least in recent years would include
Benedict Cumberbatch's version of
Sherlock I would say ah there's a quote
from Moffat that says like he refuses to
make him asexual because that's not fun
but I do believe that like Arthur Conan
Doyle totally made him asexual I mean
yeah they didn't have the words cuz it
was like Nike know whatever yeah the
word didn't examine the thing about
Sherlock as a character and obviously
he's open to interpretation he's been
radically reinterpreted repeatedly and
so I'm not saying Moffat had to do it a
certain way but it you
the thing about Sherlock in the books is
that if he has a sex drive his interest
in that the ranks below about a hundred
other things that he's way more
interested in so like I he strikes me as
probably one of the bigger names that
strikes me as a valid um
headcanon I know for myself and I get
into arguments with people over this one
my head Canon is that the Joker is
asexual my reasoning for that might be a
little weird though that's the reasoning
well the thing is I feel like for him
having a sex drive is too normal
and that sounds awful I don't mean like
it's abnormal to not have a sex drive
but I mean like the idea that that
because most people bring up the idea of
him and sexuality in relation to Harley
Quinn yeah in my mind like he's not I
don't believe him to be sexually
attractive doing what he's doing with
her aside from being really screwed up
is I can't imagine it motivated by
something as commonplace as sexual
attraction that's too normal a
motivation for somebody like that I feel
very I I can't imagine in my brain like
a scene where he's just like I don't
know yeah like Harley is hardcore
attracted to him yeah oh yeah oh yeah
but I don't think that's reciprocal at
least again as with most headcanon you
have to often choose specific things to
disregard yeah I know um a big one from
movies would be Elsa yes she's I think
there's been probably equal ahead can
and pushing for her to have a girlfriend
although I feel like asexual is a better
fit at least based off that first movie
there's nothing to say that she's a
lesbian like of course she can be a
lesbian because she doesn't really
interact with anyone that's a girl
that's not on us so if that would be
weird of course right yes know if she's
attracted to women but I still feel like
it that could have been shown if that
was where they were going to go right
and of course hide it under the radar
right because it's Disney and you want
to make like a huge stand about
something right unless it's more than
five seconds
yeah III don't expect like I would be
far more shocked if Disney confirmed her
as a lesbian then if they Wow
I wouldn't expect them to confirm her a
sexually either but I wouldn't be
shocked if they just never romantically
pair her at all which i think is great
whether she's asexual or not to just
have you know you can have a woman
without having a romantic you know
relationship it's not needed well it
actually it's interesting because with
her as a character because not only is
good because you'll have female gives
you go well she's not defined by a
romantic relationship but there's still
a potential one in there as a point of
reference so like if you look at
something like brave Merida is certainly
not defined by a romantic or sexual
attraction any but but she still has to
deal with this weird thing because her
parents are trying to marry her off so
it's still there yeah but what else it's
just there's just nothing and I hadn't
even thought of how just across the
board that's like no it's not even a
matter of her rejecting a possible like
no there's just zip she could also be an
asexual lesbian - this is well that
could explain her lack of like like
thoughts of it throughout you know 20
she's I think 21 in the movie right and
then she could call her don't she's one
of the few Disney Queens as opposed to
princesses so yeah huh I hadn't even
thought about usages I just remember all
the push firm for her as a lesbian I the
the asexuality flow under my radar but I
actually like that better if we're gonna
if we're gonna head Canon that one that
in my mind because this is a weird one
for me to even bring up cuz it's not
even a film series that I like but it
still annoyed me when they paired this
character off romantically in the
sequels cuz based off the first film I
would have totally had Candice asexual
and that's grew from Despicable Me
oh yeah I didn't think about that one
but yeah he seems very content yeah I
feel like he kind of falls under the
same category as Sherlock which is that
he's there are so many things that take
way higher priority than all of that and
it kind I mean I'm on record as being a
guy who gets annoyed at what I consider
to be unnecessary romantic subplots
anyway so but it made me doubly annoyed
when they added a romantic interest for
him in the sequels yeah I'm the same I'm
not huge into like romance at all I like
romance if it's like a very well done
romance and it's not integral like it's
not the most important thing subplots
that are like well-crafted and not the
focus and don't take up too much about
time totally fine but other than that
just no get rid of them all okay I have
an ally yes no I watched your video on
that and I was like oh thank goodness
trying to think I had some others
written down oh I think a lot of older
Doctor Who fans had headcanon the doctor
as asexual for a very long time until
well until Tennant basically but but he
never I am i disgraced to all nerds I've
only watched one episode of Doctor Who
ever which was the doctor's daughter um
but I've heard a lot like his I don't
know that he could still be asexual
based on things that happened I'm not
that I'm dwelling for Wow here's what I
would say it's not impossible to still
read the doctors a romantic I think it's
a stretch for the Tenth Doctor
specifically it's really I mean asexual
I mean he could but the thing is any
doctor prior to Tennant who played the
Tenth Doctor
what could basically be read as asexual
aromantic yes he had a granddaughter the
first the first doctor did but also
depending on what you consider to be
canon
Time Lords might not even reproduce
sexually anyways so that's not it that's
not an indicator of anything but when
you get to Tennant at the very least
he's got romantic inclinations that are
pretty clear and it there do seem to be
sexual ones in there as well they seem
to have moved away from them since then
which I'm grateful for
yeah it's not a show that that's really
the point of it either no and it was so
weird to me that the show kind of got
into the the whole idea of there being
that kind of chemistry or interest even
if it was one way between the doctor and
the people traveling with him because
I'm old enough to remember even though I
wasn't watching the show at the time but
I was clued enough into nerd circles
that there was a huge uproar over the
doctor kissing somebody in the 1996
made-for-tv movie Wow so yeah the fact
that that became as big a feature of the
show for as long as it did yeah man just
that one's annoying go ahead I know huge
one is Katniss Everdeen yes yeah yeah I
would I would buy that too and again I'm
going by the movies not the books cuz
I've done both so but yeah her her
interactions with her quote/unquote
male-male romantic co-stars are they
feel very mechanical they feel very much
like the interactions of someone who
knows she should be into this kind of
isn't yeah and there is a beautiful
scene I think with my like I don't know
how I was like 14 or so when I read them
for the first time and it's after the
first Hunger Games in the second book
that she's having her PTSD and she
always shares a bed with Peeta because
it's comforting to her and stuff like
that
I can't remember the exact part of it
but there's something that happens and
she's like I've never even thought of
that remotely as like sexual or bad or
like I can't remember why she's thinking
this but like it had happened for like
months upon months upon months and then
something happened and she was like oh
this was supposed to be sexual or like
people would interpret this of sexual
like it didn't even cross her mind and I
feel like if she had any sex drive you
can't share a bed with someone that you
clearly have at least some romantic
feelings for for like a long period of
time without something happening yeah
that that would be a situation that
should have the kind of sexual attention
you can cut with a knife and if there's
just nothing yeah it's like it's
friendship it's like he's holding her
when she's going through nightmares like
it's not you know no that's uh yeah
that's a good one again again the one
that I that I hadn't heard but makes a
lot of sense
another one from TV and this is that
this is a specific incarnation but I'm
on record as a fairly big fan of Gotham
and in my head
Oswald did the penguin in this version I
consider him to be asexual now I yeah I
was doing that but then I was like he
comes out as gay right
he doesn't though that's not actually
what happens so what does I'll tell I'll
say what does happen and then I'll talk
about my interpretation of it
so what does happen is he basically
falls in love with Edie the rivet that
with the Riddler yeah
but the thing is is that he does seem to
interpret that as love but he does say
you know I love you but there's really
no and there's there's indications of
him trying to get his attention and his
affection there's really no indication
of a sexual interest
and in my own head Canon for this part
of what's going on here is that he has
never had any connection with another
human being really aside from his mother
so the instant he starts feeling any
positive feeling towards another human
being he leaps to the most extreme
interpretation of that which is oh I'm
in love with this person because he
lacks any frame of reference to be able
to categorize it as anything else and so
that's my head Canon on that but at the
very least I will stand by the fact
there was no clear evidence that he has
a sexual attraction to him yeah I have
only watched the first season of Gotham
but I'd like catch up with like the news
of what's happened and stuff like that
I've watched clips and my thing was like
yeah like I just does not see him like
he's like because I heard that happen in
the house that's weird
just did not see that happening but I
like I would love to see representation
of like is pretty much most of these we
look at it it's people that don't have a
lot of they all seem to be like a
romantic asexual and it's really great
to see that like oh there can also be
someone who is homo-romantic asexual
right which could be Oswald which I'd be
like I'll great right or he could also
just be a sad soul who you know his only
connection is his mother which mr. it
was well cos it's interpreted
interpreted in different way it's
certainly but yeah it really really kind
of is the whole thing in a nutshell that
we we have to we have to go for our
headcanon and not explicitly supported
instances I think that was the last one
I had did you have any others no I don't
know
I am hopeful at least that probably
folks watching this will probably have a
few of their own to toss out there so I
I just want to thank you for for coming
on and doing this thanks for having me
so obviously you you have a YouTube
channel you are a booktuber so you
pretty much exclusively talk about books
at least so far it's your channel talk
about what you like but everybody there
will be a link down in the description
up Foreman's channel I would highly
encourage all of you to check it out I
haven't been enjoying her stuff so um
again thanks so much for joining me
thank you
yep that'll do that so folks guess what
whatever your thoughts are on what men
and I talked about asexual
representation examples of it that we
didn't think of whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
that you can do because there's buttons
and there's links including one to my
patreon if you feel like supporting me
in that fashion if not don't worry about
it because there's gonna be other links
including the 1/2 mins channel but even
if you don't want to click on those you
know what don't even sweat it that much
because at the end of the day guys
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]